so we've now made some changes to our
envision prototype we've added the check
boxes and we've changed our home screen
now in order to use a research with it
we've put it on a phone and we'll bring
in users to test with it Jonathan how do
we go about putting it onto this phone
it's simple J all you need to do is
click on the share link button and click
SMS when you click the share link button
you'll have an option to choose how you
want to share your project simply click
the SMS button entering the phone number
that you'd like to send a text to and
it'll automatically send the text
directly to your phone when you open up
the text it'll have a link that will
allow you to download the prototype
directly onto your phone and now we're
going to bring in Jeremy to start
testing our app